first can I say I really love song land
I thought it was fantastic I thought the
episode was great what was that like for
you
I loved it you know I what I loved about
the whole format of the show is it
really gives people a window into how we
really create how we really collaborate
with other songwriters how we bad ideas
back and forth when we're in the
songwriting room and it was very
realistic and uh we came out with a
great song but several great songs out
of it and and I think people are really
getting a chance to see how we make
music which is cool what I loved and I
learned from that show is listening away
you can arrange music in your head so
quickly and the way you can change a
verse or you can punch something up I
thought it was beautiful I think it's
important that people understand the
talent
yeah like Ryan Tedder when he talks
about the show he often talks about the
fact that we have all these shows well
we watch people cook we watch the kind
of the behind the scenes of how food is
made but we rarely see the behind the
scenes of how music is made in this kind
of detail and so I think it's kind of
cool yeah okay you're here tonight to be
a part of the Nipsey Hussle tris tribute
you guys had a chance to record that
song what are you what was nipsey like
for people who really don't understand
cuz I feel like the world really
understood him when he passed away well
I've really learned a lot more about him
when he passed away too honestly we
weren't close at all we this the first
time we ever collaborated together and
we shot the video together a few days
before he was taken from us and so what
I saw from him was that he was proud of
where he was from he was pointing out
different areas we were on top of this
high-rise our parking structure and we
were shooting up there and he was
showing me where he grew up showing me
how much he cared about his neighborhood
and he showed that through his actions
and not just his words and I think
that's the most impressive thing about
him he was a businessman in many ways
like you word I could have seen you two
collaborating on so many things in the
future if it had if it had come to
fruition yeah I mean I feel bad that I
didn't learn as much about him until he
passed away that I did but what a legacy
he's left but you hate for you know even
though we want to celebrate his life
it's just a terrible heartbreaking
tragedy that we lost him and there's no
real silver lining to that there isn't
it all before you go your wife it
continues to just bring out Instagram
gems I mean she is the greatest of all
she really might
the goat on Instagram has there been a
moment where you have bested her yet or
is there any work you're doing or trying
to get back
is there any way everyone's tried to
clap back to Christie and they've all
lost no one has ever beaten her what did
you do you live with her she's a clap
bag Queen she's she's actually very
loving and very fun to be around at home
so she's not just clapping back all day
don't worry but we have a lot of fun on
Twitter and Instagram too and she'll rid
me a little bit but it's all in good fun
oh one last thing on family feud did she
blow your mind when she started telling
you but putting your business in the
streets oh it was I've seen it before I
didn't blow my mind
[Music]
[Applause]